okay we're continuing to talk about the
bar report for a document that would
totally clear the president according to
Donald Trump Republicans are really
working hard and going out of their way
to prevent the Moller report from being
released and for the second time this
week this is not me repeating the story
from Monday Tuesday this it's happened
again Republican Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell has blocked a resolution
which would eventually get the Moller
report released now I want to remind you
the House of Representatives passed this
resolution 422 zero okay that means
unanimous with some people abstaining
Democrats and Republicans 422 zero Mitch
McConnell blocked it earlier this week
Dianne Feinstein senator from California
Democrat tried to get unanimous consent
for the Senate to pass this and for the
second time Mitch McConnell blocks it
Feinstein said listen anybody with a
brain understands that William bars four
page summary of a summary doesn't tell
us a damn thing we need the full report
but McConnell just says no he says
William bar is going to tell us if and
when and which version of the report is
going to be released and of course which
version increasingly a question after
Lindsey Graham said that a version is
going to be provided to the House of
Representatives and it's an important
sort of procedural thing to understand
is that Dianne Feinstein tried to pass
this by what's called unanimous consent
okay any senator can ask for unanimous
consent to pass a resolution every
senator has to sign off on it but any
one senator who wants to block it can
block it and that's what happened here
with Mitch McConnell so that's what's
happening with our elected officials at
least in the Senate meanwhile a new poll
shows that 84 percent of Americans want
the Mullah report made public never mind
being provided to the House and Senate
in an unredacted form if you look among
party lines even 75% of Republicans what
the Moller report made public this is
according to a new Quinnipiac poll that
was released this week I've mentioned
this before okay we don't have what's
the full democracy in the United States
at this point in time we have what's
called a flawed democracy these are not
my terms these are established terms
that exist for describing the fullness
of democracy in different nation states
around the world this is not like that
silly democracy versus Republic thing
that some people on the right like to
talk about these are actual designations
a Princeton study has looked in detail
at whether the United States is a full
democracy or falls short of it and what
this means in practice is that in the
United States the level of public
support for something for a bill for
example doesn't correlate significantly
with the likelihood of it being made the
law or being passed if it's not a matter
of law if you are very rich in the
United States or if you are a powerful
and large corporation what you want to
see a happen based on our legislative
elected officials that is much more
likely to become reality than if you are
just an average person so an example
would be after Sandy Hook the Sandy Hook
shooting in Connecticut few years ago
eighty-five to ninety percent of
Americans wanted universal background
checks with no exceptions period
couldn't make it happen the fact that it
was almost unanimous in terms of a
desire from the public was not carried
out by our elected officials and in this
case eighty four percent of Americans
want the Robert Moeller report released
in full Mitch McConnell and William bar
are working very very hard to prevent it
when we get it Donald Trump may
ultimately take pleasure in the fact
that something short of the full report
is what we are going to get so when you
look at how the United States is ranked
in terms of the democracy index we are
not a full democracy we are ranked as a
flawed democracy flawed democracies are
countries where the elections are
basically fair and free and there are
basic civil liberties that that are sort
of honored in basically all
circumstances but there are sort of
faults to the democracy there are faults
in terms
of the development of the political
culture certainly an issue here in the
United States the level of participation
in politics is a problem in flawed
democracies definitely a problem here
there are issues in how government
functions and how government does or
doesn't reflect the will of the people
definitely a problem in the United
States so if you look at an index of
democracy you'll see that full
democracies include countries not
surprisingly like Norway and Sweden and
Denmark Australia and Canada are
considered full democracies the UK who I
in South America is considered a full
democracy and then the second sort of
level are flawed democracies by these
same measures and the United States is
in that category Greece India Italy are
there it's a very common category
actually my home country of Argentina is
designated a flawed democracy and we're
seeing that represented here we need to
see the full molar report I hope that we
will the one thing working in our favor
is that because desire to see the report
is so high hopefully it becomes a bigger
and bigger political problem for the
Trump administration and the Justice
Department the longer it goes without
being released the caveat is very
commonly in the United States when
something just kind of goes on for a
while and becomes background noise
people forget about it or it's no longer
sort of seen as a pressing issue the
fact that Donald Trump is in the White
House I worry is one of those things the
energy that we saw after his election in
great part has dissipated
because it's become the status quo and I
wonder whether the voter motivation is
going to be there to remove him in 2020
along the same lines eighty-four percent
of Americans want to see the Muller
report the longer we see it it should
become a bigger and bigger problem
politically for the administration
except people may forget about it one
just other thing I was thinking about
yesterday imagine for a second if in the
Bill Clinton era
Kenneth Starr's report about the Monica
Lewinsky Bill Clinton situation had been
boiled down to a four page summary
written by Bill Clinton's Attorney
General
would Republicans have accepted that as
a full accounting of what the
investigation contained uncovered and
determined I think we all know the
answer to that send me your thoughts I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we'll
be back right after this one of today's
sponsors is minds.com a social
networking platform that is committed to
free speech transparency privacy and
fairly compensating content creators it
basically combines many of the features
of sites like Facebook YouTube and
Twitter in one platform but mine's is
trying to solve a lot of the problems
that exist on major social networks on
Minds you're not being spied on you're
not being tracked everything is
encrypted and private minds as a company
can't even see any of your personal data
you're not going to see a bunch of
creepy ads showing you the same products
you were just looking at on other
websites and unlike other major social
networks the code that runs minds.com
is publicly available it provides total
transparency and the ability for
developers to even contribute to the
project themselves for example on many
other social platforms you're only
reaching a tiny fraction of your
followers organically but on mine's the
newsfeed is 100% organic and you can see
for yourself how the algorithms actually
work every time you do something on
minds like create content share like
someone else's content you earn minds
tokens which can be used to boost the
visibility of your own content you are
getting rewarded for participating in
and contributing to the network and
mines offers a feature kind of like
patreon where your fans can unlock your
premium content by sending you minds
tokens I encourage you to go check it
out at minds.com there's also a mobile
app and you can actually follow the
david pakman show on minds at minds.com
slash david pakman show I've also put a
link right underneath this video